As an introduction to the main
topic of this lecture
sequence, let us go through a
simple example and on the way,
review what we have
learned so far.
The example that we're going
to consider involves three
tosses of a biased coin.
It's a coin that results in
heads with probability p.
We're going to make this
a little more precise.
And the coin is biased in the
sense that this number p is
not necessarily the
same as one half.
We represent this particular
probabilistic experiment in
terms a tree that shows us the
different stages of the
experiment.
Each particular branch
corresponds to a sequence of
possible results in the
different stages, and the
leaves of this tree correspond
to the possible outcomes.
The branches of this tree are
annotated by certain numbers,
and these numbers are to be
interpreted appropriately as
probabilities or conditional
probabilities.
So for example, this number
here is interpreted as the
probability of heads in the
first toss, an event that we
denote as H1.
This number here is to be
interpreted as a conditional
probability.
It's the conditional probability
of obtaining heads
in the second toss given
that the first
toss resulted in heads.
And finally, this number here
is to be interpreted as the
conditional probability of heads
in the third toss, given
that the first toss resulted in
heads and the second toss
also resulted in heads.
Let us now continue with
some calculations.
First, we're going to practice
the multiplication rule, which
allows us to calculate
the probability
of a certain outcome.
In this case, the outcome of
interest is tails followed by
heads followed by tails.
So we're talking about this
particular outcome here.
According to the multiplication
rule, to find
the probability of a particular
final outcome, we
multiply probabilities and
conditional probabilities
along the path that leads to
this particular outcome.
So in this case, it's (1 minus
p) times p times (1 minus p).
Let us now calculate
the probability
of a certain event.
The event of interest is the
event that we obtain exactly
one head in the three tosses.
This is an event that can
happen in multiple ways.
Here is one possibility where
we have a single head.
Here's another possibility.
And here's a third one.
These are the three possible
ways that we can have exactly
one head, depending
on where exactly
that single head appears.
Is it in the first toss, in the
second, or in the third.
To find the total probability of
this event, we need to add
the probability of the different
outcomes that
correspond to this event.
The probability of this outcome
is p times (1 minus p)
squared, the probability of
this outcome is what we
calculated.
It's, again, p times (1
minus p) squared.
And the probability of the third
one is also p times 1
minus p squared.
So the answer is 3p times
(1 minus p) squared.
Notice that each one of the 3
different ways that this event
can happen have the
same probability.
So these 3 outcomes are
equally likely.
Finally, let us calculate a
conditional probability.
And this is essentially
the Bayes rule.
Suppose that we were told that
there was exactly one head.
So in particular, the blue
event has occurred.
And we're interested in the
probability that the first
toss is heads, which
corresponds
to this event here.
These are all the outcomes
in which the first
toss is equal to heads.
So given that the blue event
happened, what is the
probability that the green
event happens?
You can guess the answer,
that it should be 1/3.
Why is that?
Each one of these blue
outcomes has the same
probability.
So when you condition on the
blue outcome having happened,
the conditional probability
of each one of
these should be 1/3.
So given that the blue outcome
happened, there's probability
1/3 that this particular
one has happened.
And this is the only one that
makes the green event happen.
But let us see if we
can derive this
answer in a formal manner.
Let's see if we're
going to get 1/3.
We use the definition of
conditional probabilities.
The conditional probability is
the ratio, first, of the
probability that both events
happen, divided by the
probability of the conditioning
event, which is
the probability of 1 head.
Now, the probability of
both events happening.
That we have exactly one head
and the first toss is heads.
This is the intersection of the
blue event and the green
event which can happen only in
this particular outcome,
namely the sequence heads,
tails, tails.
And has probability p times
(1 minus p) squared.
The denominator is something
that we have already
calculated.
It's 3p times (1 minus
p) squared.
And so the final answer is
1/3 as we had guessed.
Let me now make a few comments
about this particular example.
This particular example is
pretty special in the
following respect.
We have that of the probability
of H2, heads in
the second toss, given that the
first one was heads, is
equal to p.
And the same is true for the
conditional probability of
heads in the second toss given
that the first one was tails.
In other words, our beliefs
about what may happen in the
second toss remain the same.
There's a probability, p, of
obtaining heads no matter what
happened in the first toss.
Telling you the result of the
first toss doesn't change your
beliefs about what may happen,
and with what probability, in
the second toss.
And if you were to calculate the
unconditional probability
of heads in the second toss,
what you would get using the
total probability theorem
would be the following.
It's probability of heads in
the first toss times the
probability of heads in the
second, given heads in the
first, plus the probability of
tails in the first toss times
the probability of heads in the
second toss, given tails
in the first.
And if you do the algebra,
this turns out to
be equal to p again.
So the unconditional probability
of heads in the
second toss turns out to be the
same as the conditional
probabilities.
Again, knowing what happened
in the first toss doesn't
change your beliefs about the
second toss, which were
associated with this particular
probability, p.
So what we're going to do next
is to generalize this special
situation by giving a definition
of independence of
events, and then discuss
various properties and
concepts associated
with independence.